For women and to some degree, men today,...
...there's lots of polls on you.
I don't know that I can be the perfect CEO,...
...the perfect wife,...
...the perfect mother,...
..the perfect hostess,...
...and have my house look fabulous all the time, I mean, that's a lot for one person.
And finally, I sort of gave up the notion that I could be perfect at all those things.
It was a little bit like triage in an emergency room.
What's the most important thing?
I said I'm gonna focus on the children, my husband and my job...
...and everything else is gonna have to go.
You just have to kind of figure out what's most important,...
...what you're good at,...
...what you can let go of.
And I think that's the only way to manage all of this.